welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the finale
of season 2 is now at an end and episode
9 has a lot to impact from it throughout
this video we're going to be going
through it all and breaking down the
Easter eggs and details in it we're also
going to be giving our thoughts on the
season and also going over our general
reaction to it but out the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into what if season 2 just you watch
[Music]
so strange Supreme has been a big
character in the show with him debuting
back in season 1 I think that that
episode is still probably my favorite
with creating a man who destroyed his
entire universe come the end of the
entry we see as Sis's reborn and it
never gets put on that path of
Destruction that is because strange
defeats the devil on his shoulder like
literally and stops himself from being
born in it strange no longer being alive
means his Christine doesn't die andless
he never goes down that dark path I'll
talk about this all later on in the
video but first let's dive into that
amazing title sequence now I'm sure you
don't want a British guy just talking
over the top of it so first I'll play it
alongside how the liveaction one is so
you can enjoy it in all its
[Music]
Glory
so yeah great way to start off the
episode and we begin with the comic
panels which are the same across both
versions they obviously didn't need to
change these as it showing the source of
material which both are derived from
however it's when we hit the characters
we get the first changes with Iron Man
being swapped out for a sakar version
this one popped up earlier in the season
with it originally being an unfinished
episode from season 1 you might also
notice that the script Pages have
changed too with bannner lines being
swapped out to happies in the case of
the hog that's swapped out as well with
both his alderations coming from the Die
Hard episode Black Panther's been
swapped out with a Star-Lord Varian and
Goliath's there instead of Antman you
also have an additional quote from the
80s Avengers in which he says go bigger
go home Black Widow switched out with
Gori and red Guardians there instead of
Peter Quill now he's not actually popped
up properly in the season before so
perhaps this is something that was left
on The Cutting Room floor either way
strange Supreme's now there instead of
Thor with Captain Carter replacing Steve
Rogers we also get a script line from
her first episode without replacing
Steve's I can do this all day next is
The Shield throw before we cut the clips
from the episodes with this encompassing
all the season so far I was wondering
why they save this until the finale as I
think I think it would have been such a
cool way to kickart the season might
have been because it spoiled some of the
big moments but yeah love this way to
start it all off this video is sponsored
by misplay the 3E to use loyalty app for
mobile Gamers everyone loves playing
mobile games I find them difficult to
put down but what if I told you you
could earn rewards while playing the
games well that's where missplay come in
a loyalty app with a vast library of
games from every different genre whether
you want to play casual ones puzzle
games RPGs first person shooters they're
all on the app and you should definitely
check it out now what I love about
mobile games is that they can fit into
pretty much any part of the day whether
you're relaxing taking a break there's
always time to play and also earn
rewards the more that you play the more
you get points and that leads towards
gift cards at your favorite stores
they've got Amazon PayPal PlayStation
Nintendo Walmart Xbox and a lot more so
if you play games yeah definitely check
this out it's a complete Nob brainer and
right now you could be earning points
just click the link in the description
go to
mpl.org spers and use the code spoilers
50 for 50 points towards your first gift
card that's
missplays spoilers and enter the code
spoilers 50 for 53 points towards your
first gift card huge thank you again for
missplay for sponsoring this and I'll
see you in the rest of the video thanks
anyway we jump back to a world at peace
in 16002 since Peggy fixed the time
anomaly the timeline's recovered and now
everything can go back to normal for now
the piece is then ruined by the arrival
of supreme strange with us also seeing
clips from Peggy's episodes this tells
her entire backstory and how she's a
woman that's now out of time I'm
guessing they did this cuz most people
think these episodes can be Standalone
so they wanted to get everyone cut up
before we head into it Strang and brings
up Shakespeare who also got referen
during the last episode will has written
a new play and it's about this character
called Iago changing the drinks to
single Mals this is something Peggy
shared with Steve back during World War
II we then get the Avengers Assemble
clip from the infinite Ultron episode
and this is interspersed with strangers
past playing out too then punish me not
the world this is a line that carries a
lot of weight as strange ends are
punished in the end whereas the world
doesn't after the title sequence we then
cut to the sanctum infant and Ida yeah
this is where he went to in the first
season which is round about when he met
oang since the events of the finale we
see that he's been incasing multiversal
threats and Enemy Season ENC counted
however even before that man was clearly
Gathering into up as we see the little
GN type creatures that appeared in his
first episode also I just want to
apologize for saying man all the time I
was I was wrong to do that so often I
know you guys hate it it's force a habit
and I
apologize anyway amongst them infinite
Ultron the kid Peter Quill from the 80s
Avengers Rocket Raccoon and a lot more
strange lies and says that some of
escaped which strange tries to use the
girl trip her into helping reluctantly
she agrees and we see a strange takes
her to an observation deck that allows
him to open up portals this is something
we also saw in Doctor Strange with one
of them being in the sanctum sanctorum
in the end we learn that he's been
tracking toori who's fled to the Dakota
Badlands the Badlands have appeared in
Marvel Comics before with them being the
demon Bear's domain traveling into it we
then see a landine in which Red Skull
won catching just his head on a
recreation of Mount Rushmore it's clear
that the man he has a pretty big ego now
we discovered that the explosives used a
project rebirth killed both Peggy and
Steve when it went off thus Hydra
unleashed the Tess power and in the end
they won the war however this led to its
destruction with the weather he likely
caused by nuclear fallout Peggy berates
The Watcher for not intervening as
strange has but in the end maybe he's
right to not mess with the Multiverse
anyway from here we get some girl on
girl action which probably going to get
demonetized for saying that in the video
so thumbs up and make sure you click the
brand de link anyway Peggy ends up
throwing her Shield which kahori catches
just like how Bucky did in the Winter
Soldier turn turns out yeah she got sold
the same thing too with strange line her
as well after the events of her episode
I'm going to be honest with you mate I'm
going to be honest I know some of you
hate when I drop my opinions on the
video but I did kind of sigh when I
realized strange was the bdy I felt like
he had such a good Arc of character
growth and redemption in season one that
this kind of squand at all that he went
through in the end man just becomes a
sort of villain of the week who totally
forgets all the pain that is actions
caused the first time to see him go back
to just being like I have to save
Christine no matter what but like a
fumble to me but yeah if you disagree
then let me know below either way turns
out he's buildt a giant Forge where he
feeds both overpowered villains and
heroes in order to Power It Up K of
becomes a sort of James Bond villain and
I think this idea of trying to save your
loved ones with a multiversal machine it
was done far better in Into the
spiderverse Now where he and Peggy
differ is that she lost Steve as well
but in the end she'd never do this for
him thus everything just properly kicks
off and even though I didn't like the
plot that much the action scenes we get
were still pretty cool now up in the
Globes we see several characters
including a western Loki and a grandmas
with the time Stone and cloak of
levitation happy Hulk Hogan evil how the
duck and someone that I can't quite make
out if you know who it is then drop it
below but I think the tentacles are
potentially from Shima gorath there's
also the great protector from shanqi and
to the bottom right of him what I think
is kovis glaive smashing the crystals
like the like button this unleashes them
all with us getting happy Star-Lord a
chitari vision and coris once more the
great protector then unleashes them all
and we can catch K obsidian fighting the
Grand Master from the T Char Lord
episode as we get a wider shot we can
also see Captain Marvel and proxim a
midnight there's an Asgardian and dark
elves too when we head out we then see W
wo and vision Le shs the mindstone like
how he did an H of Ultron this is
alongside the gnome and we also get a
Hulk variant that looks like a gladiator
one then there's rocket from before with
us getting a better shot of the Dark
Elves after strange busts out he's
pulled through and we can see what looks
like either tals or just a generic
scroll behind them that Western Loki
then shows up before kahori and Peggy
make a break for it however they're not
out the woods yet as we see Wonder from
the zombie episode yikes unleashing her
horde I'm so glad that we at least got a
zombie part in the season cuz that was
one of my favorite parts from season 1 I
love the comic series and can't wait to
see the full show if that's definitely
still going ahead cuz you never know a
Marvel these days now one way to control
them is through the goddess of death and
we see fenri arriving carrying hel on
its back using death magic we then see
it glowing green similar to how it
appeared during Thor Ragnarok hel
demands that she kneels with kahori then
saying the last woman to demand that of
me regretted it this is a call back to
Queen Isabella who too told her Den Neil
in episode 6 at this point hel's Nemesis
C arrives with him once more being
voiced by Clancy Brown I am as God
Doom I as God do yes yes we know
distracted by the bigger threat Hela
turns her Focus away from the pair which
allows them to race through the corridor
however at this point they grab by
vision of Danos who appears like how he
did during the events of infinity War
snapped away we see The Return of
infinite killmonger who tried to grab
the power for himself in the season one
finale this shows a difference in the
MCU Infinity Stones as in the comics the
only work in the universe there from
this was explored during Jonathan
Hickman's f fantastic forun when several
of the reads had made their own
gauntlets still though you had to be in
that reality otherwise the stones were
completely ineffective using the space
Stone magic Gori warps him out the suit
and we sees he sent back into the main
lobby behind him we can also catch Drax
before two versions of Thor clash in the
air the Mia hitting Jonathan causes
immense destruction and Peggy ends up
donning the armor oh fits like a glove
Hey cuz the infinity GA cuz like like a
glove anyway you've got a big bloody
battle on your hands a battle of the
sexist as well with a pair going against
Supreme strange throwing dragons at them
he also did something similar to wonder
during Multiverse of Madness channeling
the Power Stone Peggy blasts at the
portal and also uses the tesak to war
back the shield it's a pretty fun battle
with lots of power usage that ends with
strange pulling from all his tricks he
ends up multiplying himself which is a
movie did during Infinity War but Peggy
counters this with the reality Stone we
then see them turn into butterflies is
mimicking how the battle with Thanos
played out in that film at this point
Peggy's taken into an illusion world
yeah it's one of them you know the one
where it's like stay in the fantasy sort
of thing Paul you don't sound like
you've got a cold and how to record the
video five times cuz your voice is
terrible it's really cool here but
obviously repls the moments from season
1 but after she spots a butterfly from
the battle she sees it isn't real one of
these days I want them to do this and
just have them like live in it forever
but and though I can think of a movie
that it does happen I don't want to
spoil it in case you haven't seen it if
you haven't seen it you need a movie
upgrade and I we'll leave it at that for
those I don't know anyway strange start
that's spoiled haven't I well it is the
channel name's there to be fair and
strange starts sending the prisoners
into the forge including a TX Peggy ends
up using the time Stone to reverse their
drops with strange then saying trick but
you see I mastered that one a long time
ago as we know he spent countless tries
attempting to reverse time and strange
in general uses a Time Stone a lot the
characters then throw all our weapons to
Peg including Jonathan which Kori has to
LIF by using the Space Magic Kor then
warps them all back and sends the
characters to their own realities pushed
to the brink strange eventually ends up
going to his demon form which we saw in
his first appearance might also notice
that he has a third eye which is often a
characteristic of strange turning to the
dark side now jumping in the air Kori
sends the stones to Peggy which I I
honestly thought they were going to kill
her in this moment Tony ended up dying
from carrying out the snap and we've
seen how devastating it is even just
holding one don't know I kind of feel
like the finale just went let's make
everyone overpowered as and it kind
of removes all the logic that's come
before it reminded me a lot of the end
of secret Invasion where it's like let's
just make it so the cars can do anything
again drop your thoughts below but it
leads into pegging the monster going
over the edge in a moment that feels
like it's pulling from The Lord of the
Rings the shot set up here is really
similar to how The Two Towers opens up
with a pair both plummeting directly
into the forge Strange In the End
conquers his demons and allows himself
to be sacrificed to restore his Universe
at this point the Watcher intervenes and
takes Peggy to the world Between Worlds
we see the Multiverse in Fall with it
having a universe shape at the center of
it this s expands down into the crystals
which gives uatu a place to watch from
visiting strangers Universe uatu tells
Peggy the Multiverse didn't need him to
intervene and in the end all that needed
was her greeted Once More by the
butterfly they go traveling through the
Multiverse and we end with a shut of the
will tree this obviously comes from the
end of Loki season 2 and I wonder if
they'll have him return for the next
season but speaking of that we actually
got a sneak peek look at it with a clip
being posted on marvel.com in the wh if
section I'm making this video just
focused on episode 9 so I don't know if
that's been released officially yet but
I uploaded it to the channel if you want
to take a look at it it apparently comes
from an episode that was supposed to
release this season but like the sakar
one it got pushed back it's got both
Bucky and the Red Guardian out in the US
when the pair were working as sleeper
cells Red Guardian looks like how he
didn't Black Widow so I imagine that
it's happening around that time love how
the license plate has too fast for you
and it's also got an appearance by Bill
Foster he's once more voiced by Lawrence
Fishburn who in this universe is an
agent don't know if that's a matrix joke
yet but Foster spots the shield and
Bucky figures out that the pair have
been rumbled leads into a big chase with
Foster teaming up with someone called
Agent Morales and a not saying it is but
this could be a version of Rio AKA Miles
morales's mother leads to a big shoot
out with buggy busting out his signature
gun and overall it's a pretty cool clip
so obviously season 3 is happening and I
think Peggy bumping into doogi would be
a great thing too potentially they could
even take it to live action and have the
pair meeting just before Secret Wars
Either Way season 3 is meant to be
coming very soon and it's likely that
it's going to drop during 2024 now I
know that I ragged on this final episode
and yet still stand by my opinion on it
kind of sucks I turn strange into a
cackling madman as he was one of my
favorite things from what if still
though I think the season was really
good with there being lots of Stand Out
episodes in it yeah they really leaned
into the actual aspects of what what if
can be which helped to elevate it above
that first season I felt like that one
was kind of I don't know like basically
the origin stories for the MCU Heroes
but with a character swap whereas here
they just went all out with it there's
nothing here that you could just say
it's a character Swap and it was way
more interesting than what came before
having just in a dieh hard breakdown I
really enjoy that episode as well and
being a 6 162 fan that one popped for me
quite a lot too I view that in the same
vein as the Zombies episode in which
they actually took a comic story and
adapted it with how the MC would handle
it like how that entry did so yeah I
thought it was a strong season I dropped
the ball a bit on the finale happy for
you guys to disagree with me too so if
you do then please drop it below course
is selling it's all connected shirts
right below the video so if you think
it's all connected then make sure you
pick up one if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please consider clicking
the join Button as for 99 cents a month
you'll get early access to videos now if
you want something else to watch you've
got our what if breakdowns on screen
right now so if you miss them then head
over there after this by the way huge
thank you for sticking through the video
I've been your host Paul and I'll see
you next time take care
peace